[Music]
health officials in las vegas now
advising to mask up indoors including
grocery stores and malls and casinos
this as people in los angeles county
must now mask up
inside even if they're fully vaccinated
so what does this mean for businesses
that are struggling trying to struggle
just to get back to normalcy
our next guest has helped thousands of
american businesses
and has his own restaurant opening up in
vegas bar rescue host john taffer joins
us now hey john
hi ainsley good to see you good to see
you too how do you feel about this this
affects you
and so many of your friends well first
of all
i can't believe we're still talking
about this now almost a year and a half
later so
there's a whole distressing element to
it there's a fatigue
obviously upon the industry that's very
powerful the sands which runs venetian
is not forcing guests to do it they're
having their employees mask up again
but you know what's interesting ainsley
is i was at mount rushmore last week on
vacation
and when you enter mount rushmore which
of course is a national monument
there are signs when you enter that says
if you're not vaccinated
mask up if you are vaccinated you don't
have to you're a couple of thousand
people there when i was at mount
rushmore
i didn't see one person wearing a mask
so
people are not following these
recommendations anymore i think they've
left it behind
but clearly statistically there were
people at mount rushmore who
weren't uh vaccinated that obviously
were ignoring this rule
so the problem i think is going to be
public response
i think people are over at ainsley and
we talked even a year ago
that we were concerned it would take a
long time for demand to come back well
las vegas is packed there's a huge
pent-up demand we're seeing it
across restaurants across the nation
we're busy from a revenue standpoint
i'm not sure the public is going to buy
into it this time and
ainsley if i can ask one more add one
more point
back before the election when this was
the quote
trump vaccine kamala harris and a bunch
of democrats played a very active role
in discrediting it
now that it's the biden vaccine
they're weighing and they're they're
absorbing the results of what they did
when they discredited it early on my
point is this
if we didn't discredit this process from
the beginning
the public would probably be far more
accepting about it we've got a problem
america's not running to get vaccinated
and it should and americans are not
running the mask
up again so i'm not quite sure where
this lands ainsley
you're absolutely right now we're so
glad not to have to wear the masks we
feel like we have freedom again we can
actually see people's mouths when they
move and they
talk so do you think that uh these
workers what if
a lot of these workers might have had
covet and then they might have been
vaccinated so not only they have the
antibodies
they're vaccinated do you think they're
gonna go along with this and will it
hurt the bottom line are some people
gonna say look i'm not gonna go to the
casinos if they're going to make me and
i know they're not right now
they're just making the employees but if
they're going to make me look at la
county if they're going to make me wear
a mask i'm just not going to go spend my
money in these restaurants
i think that's a real reality nancy and
we look at gaming for example which
drives las vegas
the longer you sit the more you play the
more money we make
you're not going to sit as long when
you're uncomfortable wearing a mask
so it has a profound impact on gaming it
has a profound impact on bars where
people stay for longer periods of time
and i agree with you completely
i think the public is over this and
they're having a hard time looking back
at this point
yeah i know we're all no one's throwing
away their masks mine are clean and in a
ziploc bag and a cabinet in my kitchen
because i'm just worried we're going to
have to pull them back out again
thank you so much john i wish you the
best what's the name of your new
restaurant
taffer's tavern okay we'll have to visit
when we're in vegas
thank you john always a pleasure to it